All right. Let's hear from some more folks
going next on the David Pakman show Discord,
which is, of course, David Pakman
dot com slash discord, too.
Let's go to Shira off from Alien,
Illinois. Shira, what's going on?
Shira, are you with us? Shira from Illinois. If
you're muted, you may have to unmuted yourself.
Last chance for Shirra.
All right. No, Shira from Illinois.
That's really too bad. Let's go next to
let's go to Mario from Maryland. Mario
from Maryland. What's going on with you?
Hey, what's up, Deepak? How you doing? Good. I'm
good. So it's a given that Amy Kuney Barrett is
going to go into the Supreme Court, which she's
just gonna go in. There's nothing we can do to
stop it. I believe so. But I've heard from some
projections that she's going to go into effect.
Right. Like about a week before the election. Is
there anything that the Dems can do to stall that
so that she goes into effect after the election?
Because I think it's it would be really bad if she
went in to the Supreme Court before the election
because she would have a lot of power to help
Trump when those cases and those different
states regarding borders and stuff like that.
Absolutely. And unfortunately, I really don't
know that there is. I've read. I don't even
want to describe it in detail because I'm not even
sure it makes any sense to me. But I've read about
possible procedural things that Democrats might
be able to try. But it's like I basically think
you're right that it's not it it's it's maybe
not going to happen and we're gonna have to
take the loss on it. I hate to say it, but
that may be the case. Well, thank you for
the call. My pleasure. Thank you. Thank you
for calling in. There is Mario from Maryland.